[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti allora come facciamo a
lasciare in eredità qualcosa se non
vediamo il futuro o anche in altre
parole come facciamo a lasciare in
eredità qualcosa se non abbiamo fatto
niente di che nella vita se non abbiamo
fatto niente di buono Ecco premessa
questa non vuole essere il tedex in cui
vi dico che anche i cattivi hanno fatto
qualcosa di buono nella vita ma in
realtà sono delle parole che mi arrivano
da i ragazzi che ascolto ogni giorno sui
miei canali Social ragazzi che poss
possono avere da 18 ma anche persone più
grandi anche persone della mia età io
Attualmente ho 41 anni che mi raccontano
di questo senso di disillusione di dire
non sto facendo nulla di che sto tirando
a campare Sto cercando la mia strada
Ecco come vedete anche nella slide
abbiamo la parola Perma Crisis che il
dizionario Collins l'anno scorso ha
eletto come parola dell'anno questa
crisi permanente questa sensazione di
incertezza che soprattutto i ragazzi
delle ragazze della generazione Z
sentono perché se ci pensiamo sono una
generazione che da quando ha iniziato a
comprendere qualcosa ha visto che cosa
11 settembre chise ecologiche inflazione
quello che poteva essere terrorismo
quindi il mondo è fragile però in questa
mia presentazione voglio parlare
soprattutto iniziando da quelle che sono
le storture mediatiche che creano anche
questa sensazione di non aver fatto
nulla di che perché Parliamoci chiaro
Siamo in un contesto dove io lo so per
prima lavorando sui social ogni giorno i
media creano anche anche delle
aspettative ci creano anche quella che è
proprio una percezione del mondo eh
creando anche quelli che sono dei bias
dei pregiudizi eh faccio un esempio io
sono cresciuta alla fine degli anni 90
cero adolescente ragazzina lì e il mondo
era dominato da queste cose dalle veline
in cui doveva essere una velina magra ma
mi raccomando magra Eh i pantaloni era
una vita bassa e la 44 era la taglia più
alta io sono alta 1,76 Mi sono sempre
sentita una enormità e da cioè che ti
diceva che se dovevi andare al mare eri
cicciottella dovevi mettere il costume
nero intero quindi capite come come
eravamo e ci credevamo adesso
attualmente abbiamo un'altra stortura
che è quella dell' agismo in una società
che invecchia così rapidamente La
gioventù sembra essere l'unico valore
uno dei pochi Quindi le cose devono
essere fatte in fretta vince chi fa le
cose più rapide Il mondo è pieno di
queste classifiche Ecco non le nominerò
Però appunto tutte quelle classifiche
che sono under 30 under qualcosa Il
laureato più veloce il primo startupper
quello che ha avuto l'idea più brillante
in tempo ma che ansia creano Cioè quanti
ci io non faccio l'alzata di mano anche
perché non vi vedo perché ho dei fari in
faccia però quanti C quanto ci sentiamo
in ritardo Ci sentiamo tanto in ritardo
poi non ne parliamo Se siamo donne Io
posso dire che a 41 anni con un figlio
ho scampato Quella fase in cui ti
iniziano a dire che devi fare dei figli
Insomma da donna sensazione di essere in
ritardo è ST viene da da tante parti
quindi capiamo Innanzitutto prima di
capire cosa lasciare in eredità che
stiamo vivendo anche in epoca dove ce la
fanno credere che non siamo abbastanza
semplicemente perché ci impongono dei
modelli che non sono realistici quindi
iniziamo a smontare prima di costruire
delle cose per esempio
questa il mondo soprattutto se ci
affidiamo a dei media digitali è
composto da bolle qui è un articolo di
Login del corriere in cui parla appunto
di una realtà ne parlavamo prima con
appunto Il frate che appunto parlava di
bioetica gli algoritmi tendono a farci
credere che tutti la pensino uguale a
noi anche perché per aumentare la
permanenza sui social ci ci danno dei
dei contenuti che sono simili a quello
che noi abbiamo già trattato quindi
viviamo in questa bolla ci fanno credere
che l'unico modello di successo sia
quello veloce sia quello che sia
ostentato sia quello fatto di fatturati
o quello fatto appunto di lauree prese
ne tempi record e poi che ci fanno anche
credere che per esempio non ci fanno ci
fanno credere che
la vocazione sia presa una volta a 30
anni non sia cambiata in realtà quello
che non raccontano Questo è un articolo
del Guardian anche se potete appunto
leggere in inglese ve lo spiego ha fatto
una piccola inchiesta vedendo che uno
molti forbs under 30 Hanno cambiato
carriera ma anche altre persone che sono
andate in questa classifica in realtà
poi sono andate anche di fronte a quelle
che erano guai con la legge perché non
so hanno fatto fals in bilancio hanno
fatto illeciti il tutto per avere questo
successo Veloce immediato ato quindi
capiamo che innanzitutto se ci sentiamo
in ritardo se ci sentiamo persone che
non hanno un valore in realtà ci stiamo
confrontando con qualcosa che non è
veritiero la realtà è è complicata la
realtà è complessa in realtà ci sono dei
modelli che ci possono aiutare a capire
un po' come organizzare la realtà io nel
fare questo tedex ho fatto un po' una
ricerca di quelli che erano quei modelli
soprattutto adesso ultimamente mi sto
interessando di quello che è la
tematiche relative alla agile c'è questo
framework questo modello che eh ha un
nome mi sembra Gallese che si chiama
Kevin Kevin scritto cevin
cinefinanza
cinque dimensioni cioè innanzitutto se
non sappiamo dove ci troviamo cioè
proprio Baraonda più più più più più
totale marasma Totale siamo qui Nel
disordine Però in realtà quello che noi
dobbiamo fare è are questo disordine in
una di queste Caselle in realtà adesso
io vi dico quelle che sono le parti
principali non vi faccio leggere tutto
perché assolutamente sarebbe una lezione
a parte in realtà può essere il mondo
fatto di esperienze che sono semplici
ovvero stimolo risposta quello che può
essere pre
post passo in tornello con il badge
quindi appoggiando il badge si apre il
tornello Quindi non devo pensare Quindi
questi sono le situazioni quelle più
semplici ma in realtà il mondo può
essere fatto anche di situazioni
complicate dove invece che le best
practice ovvero degli aspetti delle
attività che vanno sempre bene possa
avere invece l'aiuto di qualcuno esterno
quindi ho uno stimolo e risposta ma non
capisco la causa ma magari posso
chiedere qualcuno di di esterno oppure
possono essere complesse che è un po'
quello che le nostre realtà le nostre
attività sono attuali a volte abbiamo
una causa e un effetto che non sono
correlati tra di loro Quindi quello che
noi dobbiamo fare è in quel caso è
sperimentare sperimentare vuol dire
creare delle pratiche emergenti e poi
abbiamo la casistica ultima che è invece
quella del caotico vorrebbe dire quando
abbiamo l'emergenza quando devi salvare
il salvabile quando è scoppiato il covid
dovevi in qualche modo cercare di tirare
avanti magari creando magari delle
pratiche che non esistevano Quindi tutto
questo per dirvi che la realtà è
complessa è molto più complessa di
quello che ci fanno credere i media ma
adesso Allora come andare a ricostruire
Beh innanzitutto a chi diamo eredità
perché una cosa che ragazzi Quando ho
saputo di questo tema ho chiesto un po'
i ragazzi sul tema dell'eredità e mi
hanno detto sì ma io chi chi a chi do
eredità chi influenzo Eh abbiamo capito
che gli influencer Sono potenti in
questo articolo il 57% degli italiani
compra prodotti in base ai Creator Ma
questo l'ho messo questo articolo per
dire anche che non è che devi avere una
schiera di 200.000
660 trilioni di follower per influenzare
quello che puoi lasciare inedit parte
dalle persone a cui sei a contatto
quindi se in questo momento della tua
vita ti senti che non hai fatto nulla di
che e hai già un valore e poi lo vedremo
insieme ma soprattutto Inizi a capire
che puoi lasciare in identità
influenzare positivamente le persone che
si che ti sono vicine in questo caso la
cosa più semplice da fare che io
consiglio è proporre soluzioni a
problemi ma non immaginate il problema
della pace nel mondo eh problemi anche
possono essere semplici potete ascoltare
le persone che sono accanto a voi e
cercare magari delle alternative facendo
delle proposizioni questa è un consiglio
anche se siete al lavoro e magari vi
trovate in impass con i nuovi colleghi
magari siete l'ultimo arrivato lo
stagista e i colleghi sono ostili potete
anche dimostrarvi disponibili magari a
ad aiutarli a dire secondo te come
potrebbe essere fatta questa cosa Ma
secondo te se lo faccio così potrebbe
essere fatta meglio questo In realtà è
già l'inizio di quello che può essere
una piccola eredità di nuove pratiche
che voi lasciate alle persone un'altra
cosa da pensare è questo Poi lo spiego
non Guardate la slide ascoltate me è
anche che non dobbiamo avere un successo
una capacità e qu al tedex arrivano
sempre personalità di spicco enorme che
dici ok Devo aver fatto il dottorato a
princeton perché sennò non faccio il
tedex però per lasciare un'identità
veramente devi avere quello che in
appunto nello sviluppo dei prodotti
innovativi si chiama il minimum valable
product vorrebbe dire la minima cosa che
può essere utile agli altri non
immaginiamo di risolvere un problema per
intero immaginiamo di risolvere una
piccola parte del problema di un altro
non dobbiamo essere perfetti per avere
successo non dobbiamo essere perfetti
per essere accettati a quel lavoro per
fare carriera dobbiamo essere in qualche
modo delle persone che abbiano le
componenti minime per andare avanti e
poi si modifica si migliora su quelli
che possono essere i feedback che
arrivano dall'esterno quindi Impariamo
anche ad ascoltare non solamente a dare
un'eredità ma anche a riceverla perché
questo porterà il nostro prodotto a
migliorare il nostro se stesso come
vedete nell'esempio a ad andare da
quello che può essere un monopattino a
un camion però lo sviluppo è lineare non
è era dato a principio Ma è uno sviluppo
che è arrivato con quello che ci
dicevano gli altri quindi questo diciamo
è già un altro passo quindi il primo
pensare che possiamo dare poco per volta
di eredità partendo da quello che può
essere risolvere dei piccoli problemi
Ascoltando gli altri poi capire che il
nostro successo non è dato e finito una
volta sola Ma è fatto di tanti piccoli
step Si può cambiare si può crescere io
non ho tempo per raccontarvi la mia
storia potete andare a vedere su
LinkedIn ho cambiato strada almeno tre
volte e non sapevo di tutto queste non
so dove sto andando però sto andando
avanti poi c'è un'altra cosa che vi
voglio appunto consigliare Queste sono
due caratteri giapponesi Qualcuno sa Il
giapponese non lo so E questa si legge
Muda Muda vuol dire scarto spreco Ecco
una cosa che io consiglio per migliorare
per soprattutto per creare la nostra
eredità Allora sono in realtà due cose
la prima è la responsabilità delle
nostre azioni quindi impariamo che nel
lasciare qualcosa a qualcuno qu un
suggerimento possiamo anche eh C
dobbiamo essere responsabili e due è
capire che possiamo migliorare anche
questi suggerimenti queste nostro modo
di comportarsi come eliminando quelli
che sono i cosiddetti Muda che in
giapponese vogliono dire quello che è in
più quello che è farraginoso quello che
non ci fa stare bene ecco non vi dico di
cambiare la vita in due piedi però ogni
tanto Prendetevi questo spazio per
isolare un piccolo ambito della vostra
vita che non vi è di di soddisfazione Ma
ripeto non è che deve essere il lavoro
in sé può essere il rapporto con una
collega può essere la scelta di Il
prossimo esame e capite cosa è
ridondante cosa secondo voi non vi fa
stare bene cosa in quel momento non vi
attrare eliminate quello che è il Muda
dalla vostra vita Chi ha studiato poi la
LIM production System questo termine lo
Ava visto però a me piace soprattutto
perché in giapponese e questo termine è
formato da due caratteri il primo che
vuol dire negativo Cioè qualcosa che non
c'è il secondo è un cavallo vedete la
SEG del cavallo e quello è una vuol dire
grasso quindi è eliminate quello che è
di troppo dalla dalla vostra vita Anche
partendo dal singolo quella sarà la base
della dell'Innovazione quella sarà la
base della vostra eredità quello che
voglio lasciarvi al fine di questo
discorso è anche capire che ognuno di
noi è di per sé di valore al di per sé
un valore una dignità perché ha
un'unicità Quindi tutto questo processo
di innovazione tutto questo processo di
mettersi in ascolto ricevere
suggerimenti migliorare dare agli altri
crea un Unicum che ti rende una persona
di valore e questa eredità sarà quello
che tu lascerai agli altri sarà
un'eredità fatta di tanti piccoli
momenti tanti quanto le persone che
incontrerai tanti momenti della tua vita
perché l'eredità è questa non è il
successo fatto e finito Grazie ancora
Buona
serata